it's life hacks 110 all those facts
how many life hacks I've got loads mate
I got a big big pot of life hacks
he doesn't even got any like facts you
don't even have any what are you doing
definitely one of the things that makes
people week is over reliance on any one
thing every time I've got a taxi that
isn't uber they've been resistant to who
you if you use one of the self-serve
caustic coffee machines you can fit a
large coffee into a medium cup then you
only get charged for a medium that is
stealing it's also [ __ ] coffee can you
ejaculate without interaction anyone
who's listening can you tell us if
you've ejaculate without an erection I
know someone that had a poo in came
[Music]
thousands of people watching you and you
just might you've pulled it out the bag
ladies and gentlemen welcome back I'm
joined by Johnny and Youssef from
propane fitness calm its life hacks 110
all those packs
how many life hacks I think it's
probably about fifteen hundred and fifty
250 yeah only five you've run out
Johnnie's run out of life hacks and
anyway it's okay it's all right me and
Yusuf have got loads and you can just
I'll just talk about you're here for
them here for them I think we will
grease the groove in there on yoga so if
you know if you're new to life hacks is
our most popular series on modern wisdom
tools principles products very
productive and efficient life and this
episode is brought to you by total
performance it is an online course which
delivers daily workouts and training
functional movements but their physique
focused I actually filmed the mobility
course for them which was loads of fun
so you'll be doing functional style
movements but with a bruit twist which
is really what everyone wants to do so
head to toe performance code at UK and
follow the link to sign up or you can go
to the show notes below and you get
seven days of programming for free so
you can just go try it out and rinse
them for
seven days of training gets well than
that on to so Johnny what is it show me
why don't you start off I will do what
this is actually the first life hack
that I've featured which has been
officially submitted by a listener and
it's mint okay
ready for this I'm ready for this okay
so back to the screen will Robertson if
you use one of the self-serve caustic
coffee machines you can fit a large
coffee into a medium cup then you only
get charged for a medium that is
stealing Will Robinson it's also [ __ ]
coffee but it's good for the environment
because you're using less wasted cup
space hang on don't you go to Costa
yeah but not what he's talking about is
the machines that might yellow petrol
stations okay well I mean I think so and
that's like saying hey look I can get
away with stealing a marginal amount of
extra fluid in my coffee that for us a
liar is stealing so it is not stealing
because you've already paid for
well the charges for the size of six I
don't cup you shouldn't be paying for
your own front amount of coffee that
there are the size of the cup or for the
amount of liquid that you've dispensed
well he's paying it's cheaper if you
have your own isn't it there's a fixed
amount of liquid that's like the doesn't
always doing he's not making more liquid
come out like he is pressing a button
and amount of liquids coming out he's
pressed the wrong button for the price
that he's been that's the same as we're
saying when you're in a Tesco check out
just by there's a steak but say that
it's onions but I had no semen used to
do that but it's not the same because
what he's doing is he's going to machine
puts his cup under presses medium and
then pays presses large it's all right
yep
passes a lot yeah passes presses large
into a medium cook so the thing is it
does not follow that the dispense and
the pours well the thing is that the
person who's on the checkout isn't
measuring how much liquid is in that
made guys yeah anyway I think well
Robertson Mays dealer do not listen do
not listen to these two they're trying
to [ __ ] on your prey
he doesn't even got any like fact really
maybe your you don't even have any what
you doing to vertical leave will alone
will mean you were [ __ ] piece mate
yeah burgle
Eve burgle burgle he she it we burgled
they Bogle right use if you wanna go
should we go this yes go give Johnny
some time to yeah to ponder and so
today's life hack was something I made
today and it is a scalable salad so I am
totally inept at anything culinary and
my beautiful flatmate Mike Randall
showed me the way he of the day with a
he's got special knife and you just said
I was chopping wrong well this is is
tabula which is well I'm bulgur wheat
cook cucumber pomegranate if you want
peppers parsley mint fresh mint beans
and olives chopped more lap so just
thinly dice them or if you just can't
use a knife you can get push chopper
which is like a a zigzag blade in a
circular thing we put the amount of
vegetables and you do that a few times
the blade comes down and rotates yeah
and just dices everything for you chuck
it all in with the bulgur wheat and then
you can add some shredded chicken on top
you can put some balsamic dressing that
will create about a kilo of salad for
about 4 or 5 pounds compared to if you
were to buy a salad of that level of
quality it would cost you thousands
what's it called
tabula definitely it's a Middle Eastern
tea ABB is that the solid or ass out of
the device Oh have a boola boola boola
it's the salad okay yeah okay the one we
were speaking to you great from he'll
around today you have said in a normal
sentence Baghdad but couldn't say
background here to say I do
knew it
come on then Johnny hit us oil the pipes
grease the groove poker but when the
bread
button the hatchet mouths ones in the
mouse how'd you suppose that is
okay and oh us okay yep
do you know what I was going to ask you
about this earlier today because it
looks Hardy is it made of fiberglass so
if you google them they started on a
Kickstarter campaign and they have
tested these phone cases dropping them
they sent a drone up and they released
the phone's area they hit it with
hammers so it was the second time
dropped my phone picked it up a hundred
fifty quid so instead of that what when
you phoned I was like I am not cracking
I mean famous last words that I've
actually had two dreams where I've
cracked the screen of this but yeah they
it's really nice service is really good
and I think looks pretty cool on that
one thing that I am going to criticize
it is how in love with the fact that it
had a magnetic wallet that could go on
the back of it you weren't and you
weren't adamant the [ __ ] adamant I'll
just show this to the camera no it's not
it's not absolutely adamant about the
physical this is making a card holder
here on the back of the on the back of
the phone case because it's got a little
magnet behind that was a great idea and
he dispensed with your wallet and then
your girlfriend's brother said to you
what what if that just comes off me
because I'll don't bite he delivered it
it ate here warm to double punch the
second it was knock out was what are you
gonna put in that and I was like oh well
it's so you know I'm night out you go
out you don't you think oh I don't need
my car to use Apple pay so I'll put my
you know put my driving license in and
stuff like that you can't be driving
licence in that oh yeah you know what
unity when you take it out here pocket
and it slips off you've got I had a
couple of drinks and you wake up the
next morning use don't have like your
National Insurance cut number and your
driving license so do you take your
National Insurance number on a night oh
dear
well it's like registering nice
encounter something that we did it today
I needed my National Insurance I'm not a
yeah he knows off the top of his head so
do I don't do credit cards no longer get
affected by magnets partly not awesome I
suppose I'd be screwed
if I was the case cuz I've got a magnet
there in fact that's a bonus life hack
I've got a magnet behind my phone case
there right so that when when I'm in the
car you know you have the vent things
just a ballistic that yes you can just
stick it on there so I have the you
don't also criticize me for that yeah
yeah so in my on my event the the fault
in design with that is the thing how it
fits into the vent but so yeah you just
go okay flips up now this is the best
thing about this inside here when you
take this out for you which I'm not
going to do because it's a right thing
to take off you know the thing that you
need to take your SIM card out mmm
that's been the case make it sounds
really innovative
I just you ruined it for me when the
first thing you did was attach the most
important cards in your life to the back
of it with magnets yeah so anyway oh us
good this is a recent relatively recent
one which is scheduled send on gmail I
don't know if you've seen this I don't
whether you use web based Gmail anyone
it doesn't and you'll see now at the
bottom if you go on to written your
email out you go to send and just next
to send there's a little drop-down arrow
that allows you to schedule it so you
can be working away on a night time or
in the morning have emails that you
require to arrive with someone and just
schedule them for mail but the slowly
getting chipped away by Gmail I'm
noticing a lot of the functions that we
were espousing with mail burglar a few
episodes ago and now like just getting
integrated but she's in a cup did you
pay for mail but no so that they are
basically pushing me out the upper
making me pay Wow random excuse me I'm
not interested knowing about it
it's it feels very beanie to me there's
bean sauce all over yeah isn't it keeps
[ __ ] crashing they keep like when I
start and I'm really worried about
because I've got a big backlog of
because it puts them in a separate
folder when you shed you with messages
I'm worried that if one day mail book
doesn't
properly and it just fires out all of my
life all you lose messages you scheduled
Oh like loads of sneezed and sheduled
and follow-up ones and but it's a really
intricate like a house of cards sisters
that are needing new devices because I
have like just clocked that's the same
reason that's the exact same reason as
to why I'm terrified of moving my
reminders from future reminders on Apple
over two things and fully migrating
because if things breaks I know that
Apple reminders doesn't and if things
breaks at some point the entire
structure upon which my life is
predicated it's horrible isn't it fall
to the ground around suddenly you send
out an email that was scheduled for July
that says hey Kevin how's the twins like
also I'm gonna put on the end of that as
well
schedule send on gmail is in there but
Lin do on Gmail's also that we've got a
five-second window after you send it
waiting just five seconds ten us a man
sixty and I've been caught like at fifty
five seconds before just off quick like
five is not only your humans in the
minute where like you sit there so
sometimes either the circumstance will
change or you'll see another boy within
the minute of when you sent it happens
so how fast paced is your life are man
I'm [ __ ] telling you the mileage of
it no these guys you see another email
that sent from the same person that
changes the whole thing or you just
think of something else put in per at
least a minute I'd say ninety so just
think you can customize it no email is
that religion that it needs to be said
within five seconds of thinking time how
often do you two both Chucky mer very
more frequently than I'd like to that
that's also my time but I think probably
once per 90 minutes or once per hour
okay I'd love to be able to church her
check it like twice a week I just think
that would be advanced what's to yoga
for taters once a week when this
afternoon that's a stressful time
through he loves it he says that he gets
he gets really amped up about it and
starts sending off emails every five
seconds so he just looks paying into it
he's like and once you start going you
know you're just churning through the
man and he's like talking about you like
it to
he liked it so much no no he likes he
likes doing the deep single-task like
the constant it does feel like you got a
pile of papers and you're just going
nope bin yep send thread back and then
just person that the first person goes
it's back on your fire yeah no no no you
just got to hope that they do or
schedule send everything for after when
your window ends a lot of people do that
yeah kind of like a lot of people do it
for the end of the workday or whatever
and then just stop people from creating
threads yeah that's a cover a cut way to
do things
scope what we got well things in your
out of office I heard it a comedian
talked about this the other day he said
just don't use the word myself like I am
currently out of the office please
contact myself upon the retrieval and
the return of white or just why use that
kind of out of office replies I've never
had an out-of-office reply you know you
have an autoresponder on your email
dickish thing I've seen at the moment is
someone who is someone on our email list
you auto-replies say I'm now using a
service in order for you to reach me you
must pay one pound to charity or it's
like me you need to sign anything for
you to be on the email list this office
that you need to send five P in Bitcoin
so that I can it's like Christ but yeah
you've opted it in for this so it's up
to you whether you were single vault but
probably what we got so is another like
this is a triple life hack that all we
found out just before recording that all
three of us do mmm-hmm that is keeping
flip flops next to the back door of the
house so if you need to take the pins
out to pop out what are the plans
whatever it is so so grown-up
then put the quick-release footwear
isn't it quick-release yeah I mean I've
just I picked the most ridiculous power
of
Primark flip-flops that I can find and I
think they're bright orange orange a
pink and they say why not on them and
I'm just like you know that there's no
toe hole it's just like here the sliders
not flip Rock sliders okay there's no
phone America yeah Australians call them
thumbs down there yeah well that's in
technical terms
what are suppose to see it's a little
bit I have for anxiety
zennith got a look Havana's flip-flops
are by far the most comfortable
flip-flops Premier League yeah but I get
fun what is still anxiety when you are
early really happens in foreign
countries you're wearing flip-flops
because you are them constantly when
it's hot and you're going down a slight
decline maybe for you're a bit wet a lot
of pressure on the phone okay break it
open you think God my basically my
bodyweight is relying on there's this
pretty fem a-- bit of rubber if it goes
on [ __ ] seven flemeth
we need to stop bringing up references
that i wish i wasn't little people
thousands of people that are listening
if you don't understand
white that just make that and then I
have to like we always said it was gonna
happen
we stayed in the place couldn't take it
seriously
I wish can deny to capture somewhere
permanent the moment where you and I
Chris realized hopeful that was when we
got soaked by that car it's it's the
moment we walk out of the Airbnb to the
taxi and I tell you and go it is quite
both me and journey went on a night out
in Iceland wearing shirt because we
looked we looked on the i-ight in
November right Iceland November shirt
Jordi's [ __ ] northern lads yeah Oh
handed to us that I wasn't the coat
let's look at my to me like absolutely
you did have gitis right Johnny if you
got one not really
okay chase I can't say it but it's awful
well bigger than diversify your
personality I mean we celebrate this to
be better or worse no I'll explain what
I mean alright then this one before
don't think something about you know you
have a bad day
hums old time yeah normally it's a bad
day in a domain right so like keep our
day at work he wants outage it exactly
so like only a really really bad day if
it's like five million five yeah that
has actually happened nice things yeah
[ __ ] they work you go and you can't even
like can't even unrack 100 kilos are
being feeling too heavy you go home you
have an argument the girlfriend Netflix
won't work you can't go you feel so
tired you just can't sleep
mm-hm you remember the words put but
yeah so it's I suppose it's an argument
have you loved so much but it goes to
waste
stop stop oh is that like Snow Patrol
reading some lyrics and ignite your
bones Easter bunnies please for the love
of God stop right moving on Johnny :
yeah right um yeah so for me something
recently that I've done for this is golf
okay
it's more win it's just so you have a
[ __ ] they [ __ ] time the gym why would
you pick a sport like golf because no
one even Tiger Woods doesn't have a good
time at golf the perfect nude golf is
the sort of it the reason why Golf is
it's frustrating a lot of the time but
as a result when something goes slightly
well it's amazing so it is the advice to
diversify your personality it's not with
like oh no no right like you can do what
you want but like don't just have don't
just have like work and TV well don't
just have like work the gym and TV
because all that's going to happen is
you're exposing yourself to this
situation where as you said if you have
a [ __ ] Jim session and a bad day at work
like you've got nothing no [ __ ] cares
even if it's even if it's like play
video games or playing Warhammer or like
something like that like have something
where you just go into a different world
for an hour you're right you're
progressing in that world as well as
it's a really good point actually the
fact that the times in my life where
catastrophes hit more easily is when I
haven't hedged my life across multiple
domains I won't ever let diet or
training or friends or relationships or
what anything else go to waste and then
work has a catastrophe mm-hmm so much of
my focus and my mental space is taken up
at work mmm that it's like well this is
99.9 percent of me your gain annihilated
here so yeah like I like the idea of
things in interest as well like if
something come becomes boring or you
have to not do something for a billion
every ten somebody else where you got
like six things you're really interested
in like you love reading about loving
listening so I think I think that is the
serendipitous reason for my apparent
resilience with back pain with with back
a back injury was because like that I
was competing in powerlifting go back
injury and because I hadn't invested 99
percent of my personality in being a
power lifter and having a big deadlift
it meant that you can then just pivot
enlarges change training goal not just
focus on some of the things whereas like
you do see some people especially a
powerlifting competitions that just have
gone full power lifter well their crummy
long hairs it's a meth or always what
piers there is with safety pins used to
play bloody knuckles in school yeah that
goes away it's like it's not just I
can't be I'm not part of it anymore so I
don't make who the [ __ ] I might its I
was chatting to you Jordan about this in
the gym about how something that
CrossFit has going for it is you can
have a [ __ ] like you can have a [ __ ]
year with your Olympic lifts but still
hit pb's every session
you can be fun it can be weaker you can
be weaker with strength and yet complete
workouts more quickly yeah so that in
and of itself is diversified whereas
power of thing Olympic lifting strongman
lesser bodybuilding definitely so I only
there's a micro macro doesn't
diversification like as you've said that
with with training for strength
just if you focus all your attention on
hitting
one rep max PB and you don't hit one for
a year you've failed whereas if you
complete a workout faster you get more
reps you can you improve your form you
improve the number of reps you can do on
a new movement any of those things at
different ways to progress you know you
reduce your rest period between two
movements all those things are other
ways to hedge and still make little mini
wins without those levels to all of this
right because we could take like fitness
or exercise and scan out even further
from that and be like right well yeah my
powerlifting sucked but I'm also getting
my fitness up I do learning a slackline
whatever exactly so even within domains
and then within specific subjects within
those domains yeah I think definitely
one of the things that makes people week
is over reliance on any one thing and
that includes a person there's nothing
more scary for me than wanna see the
young lads that work for our company and
it always happens over the years someone
ends up gaining a girlfriend and it may
be the first serious relationship or
whatever it is and I just see them begin
to Lynch in more and more of their sense
of self-worth around this other person
because at least if it's powerlifting or
training others even kind of business
you've got a crack at being world-class
at that thing not not only that but
you're in control like you are
absolutely at the mercy of the whims of
someone else like if they have a bad day
or they decide they want something else
so really anything that you can do about
that so yeah absolutely I mean I think
you've come up with out of the fact you
thought it might benefit so more I mean
your body that one life actually it's
really good but yeh the issue is how do
you how would you do the deploy that
look yeah well I think for me the reason
I mention golf is like just pick
something else to spend a bit of time
doing because it's just something that
you know when you're like stuck in your
head space of likes things aren't going
very well you need it for me anyway I
can't sit and just watch TV and relax
because my mind just latches on to you
that other thing whereas if
I can go and do something where I golf
you still have a goal but it's outside
of you free yeah well it's like it's
just a little game you couldn't be where
I thought period of time the only thing
that matters is completely arbitrary
things but it's all that matters and
when you come back to the thing you were
worried about before it's never it's
never valued you never aspire I suppose
as well when you're doing something
that's relatively mutely the newt gains
a soldier yeah that's why I was saying
that the slacklining thing I've never
become so much better I was having intra
session progress hmm like I haven't had
intra session progress in anything since
I learned to muscle up in CrossFit yeah
I start the session couldn't stand it a
session could you like how many times do
you do something like that way
especially as you get older the games
are so [ __ ] marginal that you need to
look at them on a yearly annual basis to
even see movement and it doesn't matter
how pointless that thing is whatever it
is that you doing feeling like you got
that is one of the best feelings ever so
just give me some and run the biggest
smorgasbord I get things to wait on that
lovely next up to apps that will make
creating content for social media
infinitely easier canva and unfold so
unfold I may have mentioned in passing
before but canva is a new one that I've
been sent by come who is the person
behind Sony's website good knowledge
base for all things to do with online
online content these is canva and it is
just this huge pre-made library of
templates made by other people like real
bits of content and then just look like
professional flyers or Instagram stories
and you can create whatever saying you
want so a facebook cover photo or a
Facebook event photo or Instagram 916 or
square or whatever like all different
Twitter photos everything every
different turn
you can think of and the pro version has
some extra features but you don't need
it so you can get the free version and
you can just customize everything you
have all of these really great-looking
Flyers you see when you're like [ __ ]
hell that's min then you go on to it and
you can edit and you can just take
someone else's design redoing it a bit
and then that's your stuff it's amazing
we estimate that we probably saved it'll
be at way to the thousand our amazing
designers from using canvas if we were
to go back because we get a bit
trigger-happy with canva even but if we
were to go back and say like price up
all of the things we've made with
convert as if it were to be made by a
designer even if it's like not quite as
good it took you like a minute and a
half to make do you do on mobile is
there a desktop version yeah there's the
web version already good feel 16 on my
body I just can't do anything on a
mobile like I think you do have the
smaller size me eleven you nobody's next
week yeah mais it isn't that isn't that
like I'm just still right it'll be a few
a lot probably every three of it is Thor
device upgrade with it cuz I'm sure I'm
just amazed that you're not going for
like the 7d for something you know I
mean like you going for I just think
it's I'm due for an upgrade it's it's
not for the mainstream the one that's
just being the horns clutch it's cheaper
than the Exxon really not the 11pro so
there's a pro oh yeah doesn't allows
cheaper than the XR it'll be cheaper
than the XS and probably not cheaper
than the XR cheaper than the XR was and
XS is the bigger one XR is the Nomex
it's the XS max that's the bigger one XS
is smaller than the XR I think they're
both the same size so I think it's I
mean do you live in every NSA's thing
something that I think's right Dean's
gonna not if it's right to the X s then
it's the XR then it's the XS max in
terms of size and the X is the same size
as the XR d this is disappointed or am I
wrong 10x but anyway moving on Saif
what's your next life act so we'll go
for another digital one yep you wouldn't
soup brave browser did we discuss this
last time
so this is in Havanese in Qatar a bean
casserole this is a basically Chrome now
it's a different browser I resist the
idea of using a new browser do you think
that I've got all the favorites and
bookmarks set up and and all the
extensions is gonna be a bore late to
switch over but brave is essentially
chrome plus privacy improvements and
speed improvements so it was seamless
like you open it up and it just imports
everything over from chrome but it's
just faster stops all kinds of popups
and ads and all that kind of stuff and
it's just quicker and it looks nice
there has a really cool logo so I made
the switch much more amenable to that
than something like Firefox or opera or
Rocky now have you ever gone back and
used Firefox or opera now or Windows
like Internet Explorer I have to use
Windows Explorer in hospital and it is
infuriating I just think there's a
what's the problem with chrome chrome so
the interview that christed recently
with the Facebook mentor was Roger
McNamee Roger Mahony
was just saying if you have an Android
device or anything Google he thinks
Google is the most insidious company
because he says like an Android device
is effectively a Scout data vacuum for
just any and it's just totally shameless
it will just take anything that you that
is within reach even if you were like
relatives and people who don't even have
like yeah he was he cane gave some
pretty scary stats about the fact that
Google's able Google and Facebook are
able to make profiles about people who
don't have accounts so if multiple
people are referencing the same person
or trying to tag them or do whatever
they want it will create a profile of
this person pending their like
appearance within the sphere yeah I
don't have something I think it's Google
something called the creepy lund we have
a creepy line of like what this is a
program behind you is called DD trust
this computer it's alright yeah yeah
yeah that these big tech companies have
rather than worrying about like data
privacy they call it the creepy
so it's like at what point is this
deemed bit much right obviously that is
completely subjective moral line of like
that's interesting I I said I I quite
try I don't know why maybe it's
misplaced but I feel quite comfortable
with Google they're a great company for
what they offered the service that they
do no but I do think like it's annoying
because I really want to love Safari but
it just doesn't have the sauce oh yeah
yeah it's Safari would have been great
because it would have tied in all the
stuff for me on mobile been so much time
on mobile got all of my presets on there
so I have to have passwords all saved
for desktop through chrome that
passwords all saved on so it's like he's
LastPass on Chrome and then like Safari
has all the native Apple password stuff
in it almost [ __ ] great yeah did you
safari on your phone no he's brave on
the phone as well well so you've
switched across on there is I'm fully
fully moved over and this is there's no
regrets this is the genesis of a Scooby
problem is we're watching it the Genesis
must go problem or in six months I'm
with but the thing is you just feel like
using Pro like it's not like that's
exactly what the genesis of a skill
because I would say maybe what's their
motive
what is brave browser trying to do
that's that is a good point so you dated
to do like follow me can you imagine so
that ironically probably that is exactly
what the tractor right Johnny do you
want to do one our I've got I've got a
million I've got one that's a that's
really new and I probably don't this is
the same I feel like I always recommend
something untested throw us up throw us
out at nought point five version come on
the ready state Peaks tit Peaks did so
Chris went to America Chris came back
from America and told me to stop doing
wrong WOD which is very sad day but it
was G McGill right saying it's bendy
bendy combined with whatever you lived
based
have you lived in I think I don't I
think that there's some types of
physiologies rawat can create a
environment which predisposes you to
injury and CrossFit and and I think that
myself and you have that particular type
of EF body so I advise Johnny for a
period to stay
doing some more stiffening of the spine
rather than increasing flexibility in
the spine hmm
which he did but mornings without
stretch even I now as someone who is
fully dedicated to back rehab and I just
love to just lie do someone get that
stretch response on I think it is there
is the relaxation the mental benefit
rather than the focus on the breath you
know you don't really change anything
yeah well you don't like to stand up and
think man I've got so much short range
of motion in this joint you just feel a
bit better calyx tourette had the
mobility WOD launched it like ten years
ago
and what here and what beer on a long
time it's kind of morphed over the years
from being very scattergun YouTube
videos that were all over the place to
apps that were trying to program things
but there wasn't really any logic to the
programming i've tried his app several
times and left it because it just isn't
what you want he's completely rebranded
the ready state of ready state I think
his wife is now the CEO and he's
basically the talent like he's the front
front guy but he's not allowed to do
anything pops because I think he just
gets too excited okay but now there is
basically in the app is a 14-day free
trial pre-workout post-workout daily
maintenance you pick the time you've got
available you picked the equipment
you've got access to you and it's just
fully guided as well
rather than how it used to be which was
like instructions put this ball in your
hip for 10 minutes alright see you later
and you know okay but thankfully dr.
McGill introduced me to Kelly's threat
shows coming up next I remember he is a
funny man
I'm excite speaker man it seems like a
real character yeah which which I think
Abby will be cool also got Dave Tate
also they also got Aubrey Marcus also
got the Rob the guy behind strength
first Pavel's
Pavel's place
some even touch Selena I've gotta hit
the the director of strength director of
strength what a job title [ __ ] me
you better be strong anyway it got some
cold cuts would kill people do any
strong really really nice things like a
cow bright rock kettlebells even jerk or
something like that
I'll tell you should get up that's all
I have gotten enough of salute [ __ ]
Elton X is everyone ready let's do it
right so um this is a tactic which you
will both have been subjected to and it
is create group chats for people that
you're introducing so let's say that I
need to introduce Yusef to masseuse he
wants to get a massage from someone that
I use I then rather than being like
here's the thing I'll send him an email
and then copy them both in I'll just
create group chat hi people hi to people
this is this this is why he's here I'll
leave you two to crack on then just
immediately exit the group and it's a
really nice way of within a minute just
condensing down the entire task of
whatever it is that you need to do and
then you leave those two people to crack
on
you've given both of them each other's a
phone number so it's not like hang on
who this person that's texting me oh it
must have been this this their group and
you it's it's easy it's super for extra
amusement as well you can just do it
between two random people and just watch
they claim where they both have skills
that neither of them have something I
saw that I think I sent you the guide
there on Facebook where he added
everybody on Facebook with the same name
as him I've been added to I've been at
it too it crisp organized a group of
Christopher williamson's yeah and then
like some the guys written like well
well how's it really doing and then
someone's written like [ __ ] off you yeah
cuz well I did it recently I I tried to
include an Alex Williams you know in a
thread and it wasn't in just someone
else could I like swirling that I
thought yeah this is fine and then
Johnny sent me a text makes it that day
of just this guy on a beach like do you
know this man
no that's who you've added to me the
threat was the first big muscular man
was there anything it's a confidential
yeah
no person's later okay right Yusef I
recently bought a water flosser oh wow
okay so this is we've gone from flossing
in the shower yeah I've doubled down
with flossing recently well I think
cause of the Flay ssin because of the
deflation
this was after having a chat with Dean
Sandlot who is a man he's a farmer colin
pharmacologist Irish McCullough lean
chemical pharmacologist man for the PhD
knows a lot about supplements drugs
bodybuilding okay that kind of thing and
he said the highest yield thing you can
do to reduce your CRP which is an
indicator indicator of inflammation
it's flossing c-reactive protein yeah so
methylation floss then you are into the
problem of P fast P FAS which is a some
kind of poly floor whatever in floss
that leaks into your bloodstream
estrogenix oh you know you and the
estrogen adjust a wall more running away
from me some you know I'm like the snaky
in my tail so I thought right water
doesn't have either one doesn't have
enough filtered water
yeah this is a this is a device
obviously made in China
you press and you fill it with water in
each case but it's so powerful like a
test of it and who looked like held it
just against the wall and it went up
against the back wall of the bathroom
but with no drop in pressure and it was
like a battery powered battery powered
yeah and so you can recharge it and so I
put it in my mouth and like try to and
you just bleeding all over you mouthed
it on the first time it is great you
have to so I'm really pumped today 21
pounds so really eating got you to
because it I don't know why that just
clean yeah I'm really worried you saying
we're in there it's lovely yeah you know
monks the same way is like when you
floss for the first time in like a week
or two and it it's a bit bleedy
but like we got a granny water flosser
what
pick is the gold standard one that's
quite expensive I got a beam version
what's it can water what it was what
something about to say something pretty
Rupert I water be I will tell you the
one that I got it was Amazon's choice
okay alright fine people people be able
find that yeah it was just like a dental
recommendation or something I asked a
couple of dentists and they had mixed
opinions on it okay this is called fairy
will water flosser you can get a water
picks master for 40 quid oh you know
what if there's anything extra 20 quid
if there's any dentists who are
listening
David Breton you might be listening or a
couple of other dentists anyone who is
can you tell us whether or not water
flossing give us the lowdown from the
experts area please that's good Johnny
have you got something or 15 there's
high-pressure situations of people
watching you and you just might you've
pulled it out the back who's in the
hollow part that's a three-pointer from
the high there's there's an island
partridge episode on mid-morning matters
where he does that and he's on radio and
he goes I don't wanna have lunch and the
guys going so this is from via port via
a book that he read which I'm not sure
what book is called I think it's called
like the happiness experiment or
something but it's to create a happiness
buffet equation happiness the creative
maybe yeah yeah okay so basically my
brother's listening to that at the
moment is he really
I listen to a bit of it in the car he's
on inaudible I was a little tired okay
face it's very simple basically just
make a list of things that make you
happy
sit and consider that like I am
happiness I'm
penis I heard that bit of the book
biggest when and then list those things
and then prioritize them in your
schedule super [ __ ] simple what would
what would your things be what would
some things that would appear in your
top suspending it's made normally
spending time with people okay
almost always and funnily enough even
creating the list of things that make
you happy is a happiness inducing task
is that the guy yeah yeah but it's it's
a tough one
it is a several what else would you ever
know we're watching comedy yep so now
here's something else it's all coming
out these things good reason but I've
been submitting the flowers or it could
be the fulfillment you have at your work
also Trinity could be spending a time
with your life yeah average something
that came for me was mrs. Alice's have
episode a secondary life hack normally
my morning routine I'll go downstairs
I'll meditate do those sorts of things
back it comes down puts BBC news on
right [ __ ] said the death Marcus but
what about this stop it so instead about
now I just put a little bit of comedy on
on the morning it's tender people see
news what was it you can either be told
that like Brax it's happening and
everything's bad or we can watch bit
picture just a little bit picture do you
block BBC News no I don't block it I
just put that on and said maybe senior
Dave Chappelle stick their arms Netflix
yeah I've not got what we talked about
other reviews for this not me but it's
been Howard around that it had 0 0
tomatoes on Rotten Tomatoes on the
critics on the critic side and then had
a hundred percent on the viewer side
plank says it is a good I haven't seen
you that's why I was asking if you see
basically re watching like so while I'm
doing my already stays right I'll just
rewatch just a little bit enough and
Tucker picks it up just a little bit
well that's where you start your day a
bit of a lot mm-hmm I'm a dog today
going back to old life back it's even
end up really nice dream like a little
bear giggling look like that was it my
sake tiny little poodle it looks nice
spent time with Freddie thinks it in
dressing up bar big broccoli thing
oh my huge broccoli it's bigger than him
I really enjoyed the thick broccoli so
not more than him for guarantee he likes
broccoli more than you like it
considering I am flying by the seat of
my pants
you listen okay
so I've had this question asked a couple
of times so I'm gonna give it out the
favorite moisturizer that I use is
Clarence for men's super moisture gel so
I've used this it was like a housemate
that lived with ten years ago Adam who
used it and introduced me to it as I
seems to be okay doesn't make me too
greasy doesn't do anything else and I've
now used it pretty much non-stop for ten
years
what's a bit of your body that you
posterized in the last 24 hours the face
soft soft face thank you when what sets
intro to moisturize anywhere else it's
the same thing okay so don't not
bothered with that
however moisturizers Goten though
everybody you need have to be smooth
another very moist
one thing night one thing I remember
being 23 one thing that I remember being
told by a friend who was a studying
dermatology at uni and their argument
was the earlier that you start
moisturizing the better doing money in
your pension isn't it reversing
compounds
reversing wrinkles is quite difficult
but slowing the onset apparently is
quite easy any dermatologist so anyone
who knows what the [ __ ] they're talking
about please correct me in the comments
below
but um yeah moisturize for at last ten
years with this same product essentially
and sarra that's good managed to shave a
couple of months off how old are the
common doctor's recommendation is dip a
base okay I've never been much I've
never used it what is it it's just what
it stuns moisture I can ammonia doesn't
yeah
cream it's not a it's for dry skin
rather than yeah just yeah
it is not a steroid it's just a I think
you need to be very like people's skins
react really differently you know I went
through a big period of trying all sorts
of different products until I found this
one which you seems to not be too heavy
not be too light it's absorbed so if my
life--my I fight sometimes if I
moisturize my face I get spots or my
skin goes dry or greasy some days I feel
like I'm constantly almost like playing
with them and I mean I think that's good
got yeah I don't think you've got the
right moisture I think the right daily
moisturizer should be able to be used
every day without you having any adverse
effects oh honey must be something about
skin type whether you've got oily or dry
yeah so a vino oat milk is mostly
perfumers is not okay smells minion
though yeah does it what's my mace it's
funny nose no yeah no thanks no to milk
no note no oat milk no milk
so how okay I'm listening to this yep
I'm just about 10:30 I'm thinking [ __ ]
it how I should moisturize mm-hm how do
I go about finding one that suits me
Clarence super monster jump try that
first
okay okay I suppose there's one purpose
one person's either you have any Eve
perfect is it not right these clowns not
like 125 quid or something sooner 30
pound symbol 30 pounds for an amount
mature last you around about three to
four months okay so it's not super cheap
expensive iniquity is it P P mo then
between the I used to sing it at six
pumps on top six pumps today yeah but
it's the really small like you need to
and that's still not they belly can
trump or it's a fairly good-sized tube I
think it's meant for people that want to
be frugal with aches it's quite nice no
but yeah okay six pumps that's about
three months off 30 quid so ten take
your 15 quid a month like for a nice
face though
nice I mean it's one of it I think those
people see your face it's really it's up
there isn't it it's your advertising
board it's you grew up you're gonna say
it's got you and you may well do
everything does it will do but then you
try to reduce fish on do you try to
reduce your Easter [ __ ] for months as
anyone up
we know why it went up there why so
because that that's endogenous Eastridge
in compared to semi SHBG went down
Easter's unit it's not as simple as like
reduce you do not do an East region X we
do not ring me and tell me doesn't
understand yeah so mine was digital yeah
it is digital but I feel very late to
this party because I've only really
played around properly with Apple health
as of two days ago because partly used
it well I'll say I was aware that it
like it tracks you you steps and it has
all these features and I don't have any
devices that really do that then others
that actually Chris gave me a Withings
watch that syncs with your scales or
knock here now isn't it so it gives you
use you have your daily weight you have
your heart rate from the watch how do
you have a step count either from the
watch or from your phone plus if you
track your meditation if you're an avid
life hatless and only been using insight
timer to track your total meditation
volume it pulls the data from that as
well so actually now i've got on apple
health steps heart rate met total
meditation time using sleep cycle no but
I should do zone hope you don't have
your phone in your room this one it's
not a sacrifice that you want to make
yeah that's a trade-off isn't it I still
have a phone in my room just cuz I don't
have anywhere else to to put it but yeah
that's that's way that's not for like
life pack entire helps me yes game alarm
clock I see but but yeah as a mindful
minutes mindful minutes and then if
obviously if you've got like a dozen
time it we've doesn't so who doesn't
speak to Apple health really here cuz
woop wants to keep you on the app we
doesn't create hard data it uploads to a
server and there's no way that they'd
give the API to Apple so that you could
then because then you'd have the data
you can't save download
to turn you from have you been on the
desktop version of work yeah it's really
hardcore that I mean if you want to see
what's going on [ __ ] down there
that's always going on I ain't drunk I
was gonna happy me to ask you about this
it knows my respiratory rate now is that
how many breaths I take and yeah how
could it know that does it subtract
heart rate variability yes so it will
derive Tharks when you breathe in and
out you have sinus rhythm
silence arrhythmia which is but bumper
but yeah boom right so it's basing your
HRV is facing your respiratory when you
a chocolate
probably because it'll be a cadence to
your HIV right yeah so what we mean what
we mean is that there is a gap between
individual heartbeats your heart BPM is
that aggregated across an entire minute
but the variability within smaller
amounts of time is your HIV and your HIV
is affected but your breathing effect
Shh IV by making beats closer together
upon an inhalation yeah and further
apart on an exhalation why does that
happen
I think it's because you it's because of
the pressure changes in you in your
chest and it it like you guys sly
sympathetic you've got sympathetic and
parasympathetic receptors in your lungs
and when you when you breathe into it
it's boring but yeah okay you have I'm
trying it I'm trying to work out its but
when you take a deep breath in and then
slow the exhale you you physically feel
more relaxed because you know just
breathe for the next 20 minutes the
pocket
feel immediately button and why is that
so you stimulate the parasympathetic
nervous system I like to think of it as
point and shoot point parasympathetic
Direction shoot sympathetic ejaculation
well I'm gonna you got a workout to get
it up I'm gonna get a relaxed to get it
out other way around
good go to yeah let me get a workout to
get it out and if you wrong way around
really isn't the yeah can't get no
action or carnage accurate or both would
you rather was the other way around
what then when you were scared can you
ejaculate without an erection
if you're too relaxed he can't ejaculate
that's it that's why I certain bugs they
give you a man who has no Jack you late
without an erection
yeah oh the perfect example of that if
you think an I ejaculate and so on
anyone who's listening can you tell us
if you've ejaculated without an erection
unless someone that had a poo in came
and he was really worried first once
yeah I I wasn't the redirecting no
recurring thing I reckon what happen
it's like maybe his prostate was a bit
too engorged the poo coming past or
which squeezed the prostate caused him
to ejaculate and you could be completely
flattered and ejaculate it's not like
there's a one man or two I mean it it's
kind of a design floor I think we should
do yeah you know it to management or
something
yeah admin house know how I call
switchboard be like excuse me can I
speak to the person who designed this
excuse me can I speak to the erections
Department please Afghani a require I
require to speak to the manager of the
erections to be a feature request that's
also correct the bug of when you walk
into a room and you forget why is the
software problem is this off yeah
definitely it's a hardware problem than
I need right Jonathan
I'll just buy a a tongue whoop-whoop
okay
there's muses is the one two three point
oh okay so I had the 2.0
Peter so mighty recommendations for
someone thinking about weep or with it
with a tip or yeah all the roaring I
don't know that much about the ordering
I think they're pretty similar I would
say it's probably not worth it unless
you're doing some kind of cardiovascular
output based exercise so like it told me
very little on on powerful powerlifting
every session it considered to be low
strain because strain in loop terms is
the time you spend in different heart
rate bands so it only really say
something about my HIV so like all these
things the heart rate base I think it
good for if you're a runner triathlete
doing an Ironman you're doing anything
endurance based obviously CrossFit
anything like there's a lot of heart
rate output probably for the other stuff
it's not really that all interesting
with Fitbit but the 3.0 is back to the
struct butter there's a bit more data on
the app I got over 30 days of data now
so I'm starting and pay more attention
to the green and amber readings in the
morning and they're starting to tuck
they start and tie up a lot more with
how my session ends up going so my age
my issue my issue with the woop has
always been that whether or not you find
out about you wake up one morning and
you're in the red do you change anything
so I would say twice in the past 10 days
based on my recovery I'm not trained
update really and then my recovery but
massively the next day hmm
so yeah I don't heed the advice we have
trade regardless but if it's a training
day like my train my scheduling
implications are more constrained yeah
than editing it around based on what
that app says can connect so the thing
like I'm yeah very much the same like if
I really have cheese day evening to
train I'm gonna have to Train regardless
of yeah I suppose you could a trick you
could change the change the content of
the suppose you're you're never really
gonna run into if you're any training on
a Tuesday evening you know
to recovery concern anyway that's true
so it's only I think when you're pushing
your output and you feel like you need
something to stop because you want to
really I think what this is encouraging
you to think about is the goal is to
create the biggest pipeline of that
allows you to train as much as you want
so that means you've got to think more
about your sleep
you've got to think more about general
stress across the day and if you have a
higher recovery you can train more and
obviously training a lot for on period
of time decreases your recovery so
you've got to ultimately ride that wave
whether you do it by choice or you work
at one when don't feel terrible it's
very curated for trust fit very very
same even though it's not it's not
market exclusively to that Rory McIlroy
had well on but today you said hey I
really yeah so that this was a really
weird situation right won't see my
parents just got this right and I'd have
loads of questions about it because
obviously you look at that and you know
that doesn't look like your average
Fitbit one person who was friendly with
someone who does CrossFit he also has a
bleep bag when that's a we banned all
right ever else's like what the hell's
that look like you look like you just be
like a hospital go see my parents little
bit yeah right my dad looks at me and
goes that's a weak bond as soon as the
sun's going on here like like what dad
what have you spoken to he's i I've just
finished watching the golf Rory McIlroy
had it we've bumped on they're making a
big deal about it they're really I mean
his what his strain is like it'll be
nothing long days that me lots of
walking lots of you live just low-level
Abbes meat is pretty formidable so I've
tracked some golf yeah on that how is it
low string does it we might do
high-calorie output low string you know
it do you do golf does it track your
route on the GPS yeah does it that's
cool so that's that's a feature that
quite like we're on whoop if you're
cycling or walking or running or
whatever just a towei Nielsen's track
the route as well yeah and tie that in
with the heart rate
and stuff like that so my next one it's
a strategy for reducing social media or
phone use and it's yeah I need an entire
armory filled with these tactics based
on like my requirement for work and my
most favorite recent hack is standing
when I use my phone not allowing myself
to use my phone when sitting or lying
down and it's that aid of age-old adage
a body at rest stays at rest the body in
motion stays in motion is a great tip
because letting it makes you conscious
it stops you just becoming a slug of
just life yeah and because you don't
stand up you don't stand up for any
longer than you have to stand up and if
you like it's the same reason as to why
I don't allow my phone to go from my
kitchen into my bedroom so if I want to
use my phone I have to go out or food so
what's the effect that both of those
things have has a new is it that it
stops you like is it that you think like
I can't be asked to stand up so I'm not
going to use my phone or do you stand up
and use your phone but the effect is
that you just start that more so the
effect is probably both I mean I have to
stand up if I want to use my phone so I
am standing up more but the main thing
is it's just increasing friction it
stops mindless mindless opening of the
phone so it does do both then you end up
standing more and not using your phone
book on a standing desk if I'm standing
a lot how do you how do you police that
though what you mean so like you sat
down no yep well like spend on it stand
an example you saw here working TV
mm-hmm me what you go to look at your
phone just put it back down if I can't
be asked it's like I might bothered
enough for to look at my phone for me to
stand up so my no I'm not thinking or a
my phone when I probably spend time on
it it would I have time periods of the
low willpower it's like I wake up in the
morning it's 6:30
go downstairs like get a drink power sit
and meditate go to open inside time I'm
a bit tired I'm five just find myself
Instagram what if you were so enable
what's it called radar screen time for
between those hours and then wear jeans
because then you got be my big old phone
and then like really if you sat down he
needs to get it out to do in sub time
yeah you just need to be more
disciplined
Idina I'd like to have the first two
hours of my day where I don't have to
use my phone but mobility um could
always say a physical timer and then add
it mine delete insert time
that's just discipline really with that
isn't it Bhairo very very mindful very
mindful Byron Casey on a bit of paper um
no it's good so I'm gonna do another one
because I'm want a phone use here so I'm
gonna do a second one and this is what
I've been doing for pretty much all of
this year which is I have a second phone
no you guys will know I have a second
device which has my socials on and
downstream from this has been a whole
host of other changes that I've had to
accommodate for one of the best ones for
me is someone who is a little bit more
of a content creator and has to be
actively creating things that go out on
his social media is I actually record
more content now that have a second
phone so I'll have my normal phone my
whatsapp and phone calls phone that is
one that's on me at all times and that
doesn't have to it doesn't have
Instagram my account but there's a
normal in-store account that's like a
throwaway private one and I'll just walk
around and record content on that save
it all down I've got iCloud linked up on
both of my devices then when I get in I
have periods in the day where I I have
access I allow myself to have access to
my socials I go back on to have all of
this content backed up that I've
recorded am I've discovered was that I
was actually scared or I was being
hesitant on recording content originally
because I knew that if I want an
Instagram to record something I'd also
get sucked into answering all the DMS
and doing all that sort of stuff whereas
now I'm freer to record content without
that fear of anything though again taken
away from me we've got the content throw
it on line send it down the tube yep
just heard i've insulated the different
areas of my life nights an odd solution
to fix
spending too much time on technology by
buying another piece of technology
because it does work
because I think the problem people have
with their phone is that it's so
multi-use that like there's always
something to check
there's always something to look at this
reminded me of this so this is personal
Tim Ferriss is social media if he's
doing some kind of diet when it's he's
calling a social media doctor that's his
screen time so that's 20 minutes a day
one out of 48 across the week and I turn
you on obviously like the entire week
he's not use it at all cheese and then
just on on a Tuesday there's mostly
messages yeah okay Tim does another cut
promotion business he doesn't me right
and I swear he's probably got a
assistant as well it is something that
III keep coming back to I just need to
press that they've read the akela button
and get a mike phirman or get something
like Nokia 3310 so the light there no
light phone I think removes all of my
all of my reasonable objections it's a
frame three is it other two at like font
it's not like you can text on it it's
got a calculator what else has it got
over Google Maps like those those are
the fingers and Google Maps yeah right
because that's it isn't it was life
hacks one wasn't it she can do but no
news everywhere but where is it in find
yourself in town you haven't got any
cash you know I only you get home I've
got hope this [ __ ] phone with big
numbers it takes me a to the text anyone
whereas the like phone just removes that
but I think there are a couple hundred
quid yeah
look because otherwise as well you'd
have to call racist taxi service limited
[Laughter]
just every time I've got a taxi that
isn't uber they've been racist and to
who you know just you know arts all
these properties coming in the country
and there's still no drop so that you
don't be also being a bit racist to talk
to drivers but you're saying for the
taxi drivers I'm saying my experience at
any time driving is not new has been
interesting pretty negative cuz so
there's another stereotype of lots of
taxi drivers being of that origin so
maybe this is just competition it might
just be that ya the uber drivers that
because they resent uber drivers and see
them as ethnic yeah for they are the
other mmm yeah there's a really good
Family Guy skit about uber drivers it's
must be in America I'm not sure what the
nationality is that they're taking the
mick out of but it's the like shirt
unbuttoned down to the midst a very
hairy chest open gold chains and huge
meat to thousands bluetooth earpiece
with Mike I know that image but it seems
like not very common so I don't think so
like I got the guy that picked you an
American thing go there pick me up from
the airport on cheese so she's too young
to like me mid-20s you just over to earn
a little bit of extra finally has a
waiter more and more common people are
doing it you resist oiling they treat
you really well yeah well they want
five-star I think they give you
breakfast they do like they have these
like events I love what the REC fost
from your drivers I've got the bottle of
water but never at breakfast well avoid
is nice other what was a glutton throw I
hear five star rated isn't it look at
that phone for humans like fun too
it's good I'm so tempted I've quite like
from one in there that you can just try
I've been early in there from a year and
a half after I weight on here the CEO
you let me try any you let me do that
echoes this after coming back to the
Clemmie yeah man it scares me though man
and look horizontal texting I'm just
gonna make scones
it's got iPhone 11 pretty doesn't have T
because the iPhone Logan's gonna make a
mess productive this will make
and it's much cheaper damn it yeah I bet
you have you been tied in with some sort
of credit no not yet C c j+ 0 meters an
iphone one 720 pounds $350 I know that's
a lot for a phone that does a lot less
it's a [ __ ] oh yeah but think of think
of what you're getting lucky
think of what it is often not yummy but
no yeah you're right you have to call
racist taxi code right come on Sam Bobby
go let's do let's do a little quick fire
round so I had a long long delay on a
flight the other day there's a 40 hour
delay I walked for who said the first
was this going back from Croatia
so it ended up as a huge ball lake
thousand pounds out-of-pocket [ __ ] me
just generally like 40 hours and yeah 48
hours total total time out of my life
but 40 hours of the delay [ __ ] so it's
just like so the challenge I agree is to
spot the discover the Scoobies from an
epicenter
okay no I mean the problem first will
have been that he decided to use
Skyscanner dot like that is or something
of this the I think the mistake was
using a budget airline but just I'm just
using easy jet in general was it
mistakes it's all weight every time I've
been on them again maybe I've been
unlucky but they've always just okay
then delayed or canceled but you can go
to the airline direct now the
regulations have changed so you if you
have a delay or cancellation you can
reclaim expenses as long as they are
within reasonable limits and things the
online form is annoying but anyway you
can do that you can then also try and
claim for delay if they accept
responsibility they will give you six
hundred and forty euros per person that
was delayed but it although it's scaled
down depending on the mileage if it's
rejected but you still feel like you
have case you can just go to one of
these like I think I used like my flight
delayed calm or something
they take a 20 to 30% fee but it's well
worth it because they just they're just
solicitors they've got economies of
scale they will just handle all of that
stuff and just send you the the money
and you think they're cut and sewn so
because also it's one of those perfect
situations where the incentives are
aligned like they are they're backing
you because they get their commission so
they're really fighting you're courting
isn't just for flight or is it anything
further flights flights only because and
you can claim up to six years later from
a delay so if you've had a delay of more
than three hours then what there
although annoyingly a lot of the time
that the flights will be delayed two
hours 50 minutes because they know no
other gear around with I'll tell you
what's interesting is when the I have
four flights on choosing single day to
and from düsseldorf and then three of
them departed late all of them arrived
on time yes and they can be really able
to put the foot down a bit quick it's
why they're trying we had you up in the
air are they it wasn't even just a
wallet you can't have been stopped the
whole way and that's the winds like in
three different directions and pilot
just petals relations yeah that's so
nice isn't it huh Johnny have you got
one not really
alright give me a moment can I take it
I've got I've got shitloads mate I got a
big big pot of life hugs big big pot if
you are traveling to Canada from the US
which many people may do go to us first
and then decide they're gonna head to
come over there after US citizens and
Canadian citizens have a deal whereby
they can travel freely between the
countries if you are foreign you need a
separate visa to enter Canada even if
you're in the US and I discovered
they're foreign if you're not if you're
not native to America or if you're not
holding an American or Canadian passport
you require if you have someone who
races taxi code of limited
would say something about yeah exactly
so yeah I discovered this in Norfolk
Airport when I tried to check into my
flight to get into Canada to depart to
leave to Canada and they said it's not
letting us check you in it's not letting
us check you in I was I don't know why
I've got my Astor know that Oh have you
got you sester or whatever it is oh it's
something else apparently I can't know
it's called I know I was like no what's
that no you might need to just check if
you can do it sure enough couldn't flip
side of that good good thing about it is
if you arrive at the airport before your
flight is ready to depart and are
delayed for this reason or a couple of
other reasons they will put you on an
equivalent flight if you can get the
situation to saw it within three hours
and I got the situation saw it in an
hour and a half so as I was sat there
and they said you can't go and I was
thinking to myself [ __ ] I need to go up
there to see dr. stuart mcgill not on
one flight to the UK is from toronto
canada in like 48 hours so if I don't
make it to Canada by then can I Drive
through Canada so I can get my guys I'm
gonna have to buy another flight home
from a different place plus I paid to
this flight to go see dr. McGill and I'm
not gonna go get to see him a [ __ ]
nightmare but issued applied for the
visa really quick online said Here I am
hi hello rang ma'am said hi I'm a person
who needs a visa can you please fight it
out and yeah 90 minutes later they
emailed it over Wow and I was at like
6:00 in the morning 6:00 or 7:00 they
have an on call visa it was just a night
it was an online thing I just said is
there a way of you being able to
expedite this and her response in
typically polite Canadian fashion was
will always do it as fast as we can I
said well hey there's a sentence that's
gonna make me feel better
it's that you'll always do it I mean but
yeah if you're in if you travel to
America and are planning on going to
Canada during that trip you require two
separate visas it's a guess Esther gets
Esther it's definitely not dying someone
has no national
Canadian s take ya go little got one so
this is ad ad hoc o Poligrip you know
they let all the tablets and Poligrip
tablets that are used for cleaning
dentures work really well to descale
your toilet okay
keep achieving them next to your toilet
if you turned it gets scaling stick when
the moment fizzes up leave it in for a
while
wanna do semesters not do please
cheering temesta s' sometimes does
they got bleach more consistently than
infrequently when you would imagine so
there is also I mean I've gone a bit of
a toilet descaling journey recently
there's one fluids that I forgot what
it's called this great for like hardcore
scale leave it in overnight and it just
wipes all the whites the whole thing off
but recently I got a preventer which is
like the apple a day keeps the toilet
scale away you put it in the cistern of
the toilet and it's a magnet is a magnet
with some with a grille on it okay it
just dispenses the right amount of fluid
into the thing yeah any toilet yeah you
do seem to have a psychic I think mr.
hard watering plus it's sunny foot bumps
yes I got very soft hair after a shower
has very soft like maybe that's where
all your estrogen is coming from
that's very East region here I mean the
ultimate hack for that is just they'll
think we did this episode one or two get
cleaner [ __ ] hell man like the first
thing this actually a bit of advice I
can't remember whose book is boots on
how to run a a small studio gym and
their advice is the first second member
of staff that you should get is a
cleaner yeah and I couldn't you know
ahead of gain a gardener or getting
someone in to do anything else in your
house just get a cleaner it and if you
get fortnightly clean I reckon a push
you could probably get away with monthly
but if you get fortnightly clean I found
three fairly messy
hairy blokes living in a house for four
years
people come in going in the sunny other
there's been essentially no degradation
there's been there's been essentially no
degradation of any of this stuff you
know there's not been a build-up like a
manageable buildup of limescale or mold
or dirt or anything everything is being
kept at a manageable level of
cleanliness which hasn't what this one's
so like I had bad luck with cleaners
like Chris recommended a cleaner they
came around assessed the house said
great we'll be in touch
never it's not my job to yeah well that
makes what make what you do they're the
ones easy on you whether the racist taxi
company murdered is there anyone that
you hate that can clean my house oh yeah
so so never heard from them again and it
was my fault apparently as the customer
I'm not chasing up the seller of
Beeman's yeah so I looked up being
limited be militant then and then lady
beam camera and lady beam came around
she was polish shrooms didn't dental a
second one tried again and it was like a
fifty five quid where for our house that
normally costs twenty five fifty five
good for what for a house clean for a
single clean yeah which Jesus yeah so
he's got the polish cleaner I have a
polish I have a Polish feeling
Christopher for I assume there are other
cleaners who are polish you know many of
us so yeah and this is normally 25 quid
for a small flat so I was like right not
using her again third one they took my
lighters and they they like the house
stunk of smoke because I kept hearing
four tabs and just like as far as that
right not even a cleaning company again
honest so I got my assistant to source
different cleaners and go and contact an
agency spoke to the agency waste more
time they were like yet we'll arrange a
cleaner for you
it's next Tuesday 10:00 a.m. they
arrived and it was the previous cleaner
that made somehow like smoke contracted
out this other company because they were
are we and so they turned up again
but more expensive because the agency
chose to Wow you know it so looping
looping back rows how many happy penis
did you want me so meeting never got
back in touch with me I'll have to get
this with your finger this time yeah
like yours either you're not fun of your
this this yeah let me get you all
luckily there's this diff I've
difficulties or things get lost
metrology because she's that busy
because she's grody a broadcast I'm
quite jealous of audio broadcast setup
so he's not on an hourly rate he
basically has like a team of cleaners
who come in once a fortnight accompany
team of cleaners good ones fortnight
that did the complex I don't know
whether they do the complex okay I think
he pays them individually but it's a
it's a fee and they just it's as long as
it takes
same as mine is it yeah so mines hourly
mines forty but it ends up being the
same months forty pounds every two weeks
and she comes and the house is spotless
and if it's really dirty one week then
and the [ __ ] loads of washing to do or
whatever then she does that and if she's
put clothes in the washing machine we
know Michelle folder she cut away any
clothes that are out she just washing up
though right which I'd love to find a
housekeeper as well mine doesn't do the
washing I'd like I'd like the washing
down not is my least favorite thing get
your mum to do that's my sleep I hate
get you money to make a life hack
getting of a wet clothes
oh yeah well just didn't have a dryer
you know the girlfriend I do and she
does a lot of it but I still get left
with some bits how many how many baskets
do I'm into the ratio probably one every
one I do she'll be five four or five
okay so the thing is is that whenever I
offer to help and I'll do something but
I'll do a wrong and that's not on
purpose like that is me trying my best
I'll just not quite a followed the
what oh right I tried to do it and you
didn't want me to so something I'd love
is in someone's Indian grandmother to
just to come and make a big pot was like
biryani or something yep and just so
have you had an experience with like
Indian I just there though very really
industrious very maternal me make it
yeah yeah really have you probably
wearing a frock like a kind of a big
oversized a they they just it's
something that they actually like feed
off its like passion they just lose
Eastridge it they be like your Eastridge
in there what I'd like I'd like like a
CEO for my life like a chief operating
officer for my life to just deal with
Jonathan Watson Limited all of their
like the operations and all I want to do
is just what I want to do be there's no
no exist your core activity yeah I just
want all of the other stuff like the
support functions for me to just be
sorted brilliantly you know what you
should do should upload yourself to
teachable cuz they have it difference if
I could Chris I would have already done
it no less do it by Hari myzel he's the
closest guy to this
yes create a manual of himself mmm-hmm
all the things he knows I don't agree
with his approach to email though you
know we were saying earlier about how
many time you check email hmm he checks
it several times an hour it is to do
this isn't it but yeah like kind of
responds to things as they come in and
then other things he doesn't both can be
very fragment yeah really but that's
probably what we all do well yeah I was
just accepted that is reality yeah yes
anyway I think I think that's probably
with probably turn I mean I've got I've
got that we well know mate I've got
loads left you need to count for the
next one
can I my first off here we go can
anybody who is listening that wants to
submit a life hack to save Johnny on the
next episode and no it's not a stealing
one well no blogging how to burgle
better
well Robertson do not worry mate I've
got you if Kosta come after us I also am
on yeah anyone who wants to help Johnny
by submitting a life hack put it in
comment below or send it to Chris relax
wherever you follow me other things
top performance massive thank you to
them for supporting this podcast don't
forget you can get seven days of free
programming from them
just head to talk Fahnestock go to UK or
the link is in the show notes below
we're gonna do thank you to Dean thank
you to Dean the lean XD video guy Dean
think of 10 or not quite tense when did
they become the he ended he edited them
all so whether Dean this film is more
videos yeah
and even the ones that aren't video that
are audio only about have initializing
the running you classmate been deemed
Gooden gone being deemed be the yield
beam being what are we doing next what
is the question what is fitness business
principles 103 I'm gonna do a son see if
I can get business principles to one
time wow that would be we should make
that you workforce make that my course
yeah it'll get the one over for 12 hours
we should be charging and if the spit
means it's a terrifying yeah and then
you'll have to pay for it anyway hurry
like share subscribe you know what to do
thank you very much for tuning in ok
goodbye then goodbye then
[Music]
you